bo toi tu sais quoi sur le mur
ouah ailleurs ouais bon tiers sont un
peu mes émotions dans ce genre de
situation ça m'arrive est tellement de
fois me faire courser contrôler ça est
même arrivé à new york c'était en 99
la mecque du graffiti quel honneur sauf
qu'on est en plein giuliani le maire
tout le monde le connaît il a instauré
la tolérance zéro donc je suis dans
manhattan une perpendiculaire à broadway
la rue est calme un pote à moi et
derrière pour faire le guet pour voir si
tout se passe bien et juste un mec qui
est assis sur les marches
je sors mais bon comme d'habitude je
commence à piquer au bras menottes
insultes fait le mec qui était assis et
est un flic un flic en civil
pas de chance il m'emmène au poste puis
au central je suis fichée photographié
comme un bandit et on retrouve en
cellule avec une cinquantaine de
personnes cellules bien dégueulasse bien
sûr on peut passer allongé mais qui a
far qui grouillent dans tous les sens un
unique chez auto milieu de la cellule
bonjour nativité qui passerait de 30
heures voilà il ya un seul avocat commis
d'office pour tout le monde donc c'est
la bataille pour savoir qui va passer et
quand vient mon tour il m'explique que
ça va pas être facile ça va pas être
facile parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
trouver le propriétaire du mur et que
aux états unis on ne sort pas attendre
que le procès n'a pas eu lieu
donc voilà
il sent bon désarroi et c est très
professionnellement va prendre sur son
temps de pause du midi pour aller voir
le mur en question et se rendre compte
qu'en fait le mur était déjà bien
taillée plainds affiche donc ils
arrivent à négocier avec le procureur
que je puisse sortir je m'en sortir avec
500 dollars de demandes et avec la
promesse de parvenir sur le sur le sol
américain
c'était pas sans compter sur ma con côté
têtu puisque je reviens en 2006 en 2007
invité par une galerie pour exposer les
toiles et en parallèle j'irai de nouveau
dans la rue à exorciser la peur
j'y retourne dans la rue mais cette fois
ci un peu plus intelligemment
voilà donc en fait tout commence quand
j'ai 16 ans en 1989 à la ravine des
cabris
on est bien loin de bien loin du tumulte
new york et bien sûr petit village pas
encore très urbanisées et je fais si
j'arrive à avoir la télécommande qu'est
la magnifique chef-d'oeuvre sous un pont
que je nomme ball avec le recul voilà
c'était pas tant le chef-d'oeuvre qui
m'a intéressé c'est surtout de franchir
le pas le pas d'illégalité mois qui
avait été un adolescent si sages et
disciplinés
à un moment donné je passais je passais
une étape supplémentaire
bon je vous rassure j'ai volé personne
je violé personne c'était juste une
peinture sur un mur et un très grave au
final ça qui m'intéressait mais je me
suis vite rendu compte que le but pour
moi c'était pas détruire de détériorer
des biens
c'était au contraire d embellir
d'apporter de la couleur et de la gaieté
en fait tout a commencé avec ce livre
c'était en 80 donc toujours 89
ce livre c'est un petit peu une bible
pour tous graffeurs qui se respecte
c'était premier livre qui est sorti sur
les graffiti new-yorkais ce moment là je
fantasme avec ma petite vie paisible de
provinciale sur donc les bleds les
signes les quick qui quitteraient les
dans les dépôts de train pour
pour aller peindre des wagons entiers et
braver les interdits donc je me dis pour
faire comment il va faire je trouve un
pseudo parce que la région des cabris si
shing avec mon prénom je vais vite me
faire repérer donc je tourne je fais un
anagramme en fête avec mes différences
initiale de mon nom de famille et demie
différents prénom de l'état civil et je
tombe sur le gie l'alece le djia est ce
que vous connaissez qui sera repris
après par patrice comme chasse voilà et
donc
donc voilà j'en suis j'en suis là à ce
moment là ensuite dix sept ans le bac en
poche je monte à la capitale saint denis
à quoi le capital
et donc un nouveau terrain de jeu
s'offre à moi et surtout l'indépendance
le fait de pouvoir sortir rentrée comme
je veux et à ce moment là je sors soit
seul soit avec mes acolytes de l'époque
touch photo rich hip hop et qu'ils ont
formé un crew et on va glaner à droite à
gauche ce différentes graves sur les
routes mais bon mon matériel je le
récupère en fait en allant faire des
décos de magasins de bach donc j'achète
rien la belle vie quoi puis au bout de
deux trois ans à écrire mon nom à droite
à gauche
je commence à ressentir une certaine
lassitude et je ressens aussi comme on
dirait j'ai l'impression d'être un pion
parmi tant d'autres le graffiti commence
à exploser à la réunion on commence à
voir des peintures un petit peu partout
j'ai l'impression de me mêler un petit
peu à la masse l'idée maintenant c'est
de pousser le jeu un petit peu plus loin
repousser les limites essayer de trouver
une identité un peu plus forte
quelque chose que les gens puissent se
reconnaître au premier coup d'oeil là on
est en 92 et c'est que c'est là
qu'apparaît le boussouf le buzz ou que
vous connaissez peut-être je sais pas je
vois pas très bien
ah oui donc ça c'était la période un
petit peu avant excusez moi donc où je
me prenais pour un graffeur de métro en
fait j avais que des vieux bus donc
voilà
et voilà donc ça c'est le boulou voilà
ça c'est le premier officiel
d'ailleurs j'avais dit dès la première
fois que les baptise appelez-nous bouzou
donc voilà je commence un petit peu a
traîné la rue et a essayé de d'avoir une
réflexion supplémentaire par rapport aux
supports n'ont pas utilisé un homme un
mur lambda mais n'essayez en fait
d'interagir d'avoir une démarche un
petit peu plus artistique en fait par
rapport à ce qu'ils au support et un peu
plus de respect par rapport au support
sur lequel je vais je vais à poser un à
peinture puis en 93 je pars en métropole
continuer mes études et donc j'ai le
deuil en poche et je parle en métropole
ont ouvert de nouveaux horizons partir
voyager faire des rencontres partager
avec d'autres
d'autres graffeurs aussi et puis il
m'arrive des dizaines et des centaines
d'histoires que je pourrais pas je
n'aurai pas le temps de vous raconter
malheureusement ici mais voilà je
continue à vivre la monotonie de
l'atelier je la connais pas puisque
l'atelier c'est la rue et chaque sortie
est différente à chaque fois quoi donc
je sors la nuit le jour qu'il vente
qu'il pleuve rien ni personne ne pourra
m'empêcher à aller pouvoir m'exprimer
d'ailleurs l'armée me rattrape
puisque j'ai repoussé avec des études on
donnait champions obligé de la faire et
je trouve le moyen de passer responsable
graffitis dans une association dans le
civil donc je m'en sors comme ça à
l'arraché j'arrive à avoir ma licence et
ce n'est pas les mêmes facilités que les
personnes qui sont venues avant les
doctorants et
et fière de tout ce succès je rentre à
la réunion le torse bombé en disant ça y
est je vais vivre de ma peinture à la
réunion c'était un projet un petit peu
ambitieux je me suis pris quelques
revers mais je me suis pas découragé et
en en 2000 sophie d'arsenic la galerie
art sonic de btan salem accueille dans
son lieu pour faire une exposition et
insiste pour que je monte un dossier de
création auprès de la drac
bon j'étais un peu réticent et puis
assistent allemand que bon moi je le
fais et finalement avec le recul c'est
vraiment pas une bonne idée puisque
d'une au moment de l'entretien il avait
perdu mon dossier et puis de deux je me
suis humilié en disant mon gars tu vas
quand même pas compte que quand même pas
compte il de l'argent pour aller taguer
les murs a envie les points donc bonjour
parti la queue entre les jambes mais
toujours aussi motivé je suis bon ok je
veux leur prouver que les bacs je vaux
mieux que ça et puis en 2004 un projet
se monte avec une municipalité dans le
sud de la réunion
il me donne carte blanche dans la ville
c'est royal pour tous graffeurs qui se
fasse à un rêve que de graffeurs de se
dire voilà pour gars tu vas là tu as le
champ libre dans la ville sauf que le
rêve va vite tourner au cauchemar
puisque dès la première intervention
un mec est sorti du bâtiment commencé à
engueuler et il m'a sauvé d'arrêter j'ai
essayé d'avoir un interlocuteur il avait
disparu tout d'un coup il était hors
département et de fil en aiguille trois
jours après le mur avait été effacée qui
mêle ya quand même un problème quoi ça
fait des années que je viens dans la rue
jamais été nettoyée
le seul jour où j'ai un papier officiel
pour me dire je peux peindre un mur on
va me les fasse et ya quand même un
paradoxe
c'est pas grave j'abandonne le projet je
continue à faire ce que j'ai toujours
aimé faire en 2007 ou de certainement
grand souvenir gamède passe par là et
détruit j'ai dû louper quelques photos
excusez moi voilà c'était quelques
interventions hop hop très intéressant
voilà l'agencé ou à la salle va être
celle ci est donc en 2007 gamme est
passée par là et détruit une partie du
du pont de la rivière saint-étienne gros
traumatisme pour les réunionnais et moi
le premier puisqu'il habitants dans le
sud on était un petit peu bloquée et des
travaux se met en route et c est ce pont
reste la fij et sans que personne soit
encore intervenir dessus et je me dis
c'est quand même un bon spot afin qu'il
fasse quelque chose et à trois jours de
l'inauguration de la petite route qui
passait en contrebas je pars avec un
pote avec les échelles la peinture etc
en quarts de nuit
malheureusement le site était encore
gardienné et mais on arrive quand même à
passer à travers les mailles du filet on
on fait ce qu'on a à faire pendant une
bonne demi heure au moment de finir on
passe vite un petit éclairage pour voir
si on a un oublié sur la zone et bien
sûr en temps dans la tête le 4 4 qui
fonce sur nous pour venir nous nous
cueillir on lâche tout le matériel on se
barre dans la rivière il arrive fans ont
récupéré bien sûr moi je perds tout mon
matériel mais ça c'est pas très grave au
final je reviens à quelques jours plus
tard puisque j'avais oublié de finges
avait pas eu le temps surtout d'opposer
les les traces du poulet qui courait sur
ce pont
voilà en 2009 suite au refus de la
région de me laisser panne sur le
barrage le contrefort de la nouvelle
route des tamarins
j'organise un commando en fait avec 14
personnes on part de nuit j'achète pour
2500 euros de matériel on à échelle
encore perche télescopique
on va s'attaquer un mur qui fait 70
mètres de long sur 20 mètres de hauteur
pour la partie la plus haute
on y passera donc la nuit ça fera grand
bruit
scandale à la radio dans la presse moi
je fais le mort et comme j'avais monté
un truc avant pour demander les
autorisations forcément la région est
venu me voir et m'a envoyé un courrier
me menaçant de porter plainte
je vous passerai les péripéties
finalement l'histoire s'est bien
terminée merci aux quelques temps plus
tard je reçois un coup de fil
monsieur jace nous allons inaugurer le
nouveau pont de la rivière saint-étienne
il ya un pilote est à côté et c'est
bizarre vous avez encore rien fait de
sucroît
ok là je sais pas trop quelle attitude
adopter est ce que ça vous dirait vous
exprimer dessus bah oui bien sûr je
connais peu de monde dans la salle qui
aurait refusé à ma place donc je fonce
et chemin de ce projet à bien
il rencontre un certain succès auprès du
public
fort de ce succès dernièrement on va
recommander l'entrée de saint denis sur
le tunnel du littoral
donc bon match malgré toutes ses
commandes officielles en fait je tiens
toujours à garder l'anonymat
c'est pour ça que je suis un peu bizarre
ce soir vous voyez xtag foutrement mais
ce qui me permet toujours de garder le
côté un petit peu inégal et pouvoir
continuer à peindre dans la rue
librement et c'est ce qui continue en
fait un petit peu à me faire vibrer
serre que quand je suis à l'extérieur à
l'étranger les gens connaissent ni jazz
ni les blues ou et je deviens
vulnérables comme je l'étais au début en
fait nous sert si je me fais prendre en
train de faire une peinture et ben je
serai quelqu'un de lambda ont vraiment
marqué c'est ce petit cette adrénaline à
qui continue à m'intéresser qui continue
à me faire vibrer 25 ans après donc de
de peinture j'en veux pour exemple il ya
quelques mois où je me suis fait arrêter
en métropole dis pas que j'aime bien de
me faire arrêter un je vous rassure mais
voilà
trois jeunes policiers qui débarque et
qui mourra en train de peindre qui me
disent mais nos succès ce que vous
faites vous faites ça souvent oui c'est
mon métier
montella
et puis et puis finalement encore une
fois ça se termine bien merci à eux
excusez moi cette course effrénée moi
m'a donné vraiment soi dernièrement vous
avez dû également entendre parler d'un
événement qui a eu dans le sud où
j'avais mené une action avec des
malentendants fois j'avais participé
c'est papin qui avait organisé mais
j'avais participé à une action avec des
malentendants pour pouvoir réaliser deux
fresques en fait avec l'autorisation de
la bénédiction de la mairie et a même
usé a même commandé des vidéastes pour
venir nous filmer tout ça qu'on a
toujours tout va bien et puis moi
j'étais vraiment à madagascar on
m'envoie un mail où je sais plus si je
le découvre sur les réseaux sociaux en
fête le mur a été tout simplement effacé
par l'ats le service anti tags gens rien
compris quoi
encore une fois on a l'autorisation on
est tous tous mes autres murs et reste
en place
est ce ici où j'ai l'autorisation à la
différence de la fois précédente genre
soit quand même un courrier de du
responsable qui tient personnellement à
s'excuser mais qui me dit qu'à l'avenir
il
il fera en sorte que son service puis se
différencier des tags et les fresques
murales bon
à croire qu'ils ne brûlent une évolution
excusez-moi des mentalités
c'est vrai que maintenant la presse
parle pas mal du graffiti ou plutôt du
street art ça fait mieux
les galeries et les musées sans par un
petit peu du phénomène les communes et
les municipalités passent des commandes
publiques
c'est tant mieux après la bataille n'est
pas complètement gagné aux états unis
l'année dernière est un artiste qui
s'appelle reebok qui exposé au musée
d'art contemporain de los angeles et
s'est fait interpeller en même temps et
après six mois de prison en france
dernièrement ya boris un bulgare s'est
fait également interpellé l'incitation à
dégradations il a pris quatre mois de
prison
la législation est telle que si vous
vous prend en train de peindre sur un
mur ça reste un délit et vous encourez
cinq ans de prison et 75000 euros
d'amendé
voilà donc dans mon cas je veux dire je
vis entre deux espaces de création la
légalité et le clandestin mais par
contre je constate que dans dans la
société
la perception de
de ce qui est légal de ce qui ne l'est
pas a beaucoup évolué dans le bon sens à
partir de là si le blues ou a pu un
moment donné contribué à ce à ce
processus
j'en serai très heureux en tout cas il
ya une chose dont je suis sûr c'est que
si je suis là aujourd'hui et le blues ou
et voilà connaît un succès tel qu'il est
c'est surtout grâce à vous le public et
je vous en remercie